I like to call them five freedom hacks
everyone thinks I'm a professional gamer
you see this do NIC I'm a murderer I'm a
murderer on P we're here tonight at LAX
Airport because tomorrow we have a
gaming tournament at B&H Photo
headquarters in New York City where Nick
and Christian will be playing for
tonight here's the thing come come here
I gotta let you in on a secret
we've been getting a lot of phone calls
since Nick came through his pub G
champion at the 10-gig tournament last
fall in Chattanooga problem is he's not
actually a professional gamer that was a
total fluke everyone thinks I'm a
professional gamer people have been
asking us hey come on in game in this
tournament we've been avoiding the press
like Floyd Mayweather but a friend meant
to hit us up he said guys you got to
come out for this so we're gonna do it
we're gonna do it and the real question
is can Nick live up to his reputation as
champion gamer or will his dreams of
becoming a professional gamer go fort
night night in New York City let's find
out guys thanks to clear for sponsoring
this video if you don't know what they
are clear is the best way to get through
airport security how it works is they
have their own lanes no appointments are
necessary
basically with their service you go
straight to the front of the line and
you get through airport security in
minutes it's pretty simple we're gonna
try it out right now
and to make this extra clear Kristian is
gonna go the normal way Nick and I are
gonna go the fast way we're gonna see
what happens we might see him in an hour
we might see him in ten minutes we might
see him in three days we'll find out
let's go you come in you sign up right
here yeah you just signed up one time
we're going to scan in your biometrics
are your four fingers just like this for
me
we're now clear member alrighty good can
I do this with my face that's alright
[Music]
but what if somebody has any questions
about that you know that's how I smile
that's just how I came out so that's it
it took Christian about an extra 15
minutes to get through the line imagine
what that would be like on a busy day be
probably an hour or more but anyway
there's really no reason not to sign up
for clear because the first 200 people
to go to clear me calm slash Sam and
Nico and sign up will get a free
three-month trial of clear notification
squad benefits right here just click the
link and we'll see out there guys
[Music]
I heard legends of the steamy event
since this first time I watched Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles the motion picture
the real-life steam events on we got to
take a picture of this there's Turtles
under there as you might know I'm a
licensed attorney in the state of
California and I thought it would be fun
today to talk to you while we're in New
York City about some insights into the
United States Constitution particularly
five insights that most people don't
know about I like to call them five
freedom hacks because knowing them might
help you increase your daily freedom by
understanding a little bit more about
the national political landscape the
geopolitical landscape and just about
the things that make this whole thing
work number five all powers of the
federal government must be derived from
the Constitution itself most people
don't know this the language of the
Constitution exists not to expand the
powers of the federal government but to
limit the powers of the federal
government so much so that if the
government wants to say hey I'm getting
my powers to do such-and-such they need
to be able to actually pinpoint an
actual article or amendment in the
Constitution itself that says hey this
is where I'm getting my authority from
this is protected in addition by the 9th
and the 10th amendments while the
government uses the Necessary and Proper
Clause to sometimes expand their powers
into areas where it's in useful
furtherance of governmental action the
overall language is clear if it's not in
the Constitution the power doesn't exist
number four the Constitution and its
rights apply to all not just American
citizens everybody standing on land
where the Constitution is the supreme
law of the land States territories
embassies what-have-you anywhere in the
world the Constitution applies as well
as the protections
here we are
B&H photo hey Nick do you feel that this
morning's walk calmed your nerves or do
you think it made it worse
because within like the next 45 minutes
you're on
[Music]
dude we just arrived at B&H photo he's
getting ready but true but put your
battle on dude don't you want to go up
there as a champion don't put all this
pressure on yourself do you think about
that you've been playing super I already
been training your fingers it's surgery
let's go come on
alright let's do this
[Music]
good the end yeah we have a bunch of
shrimp horses gamers coming so we're
gonna pair you guys up with the partners
perfect okay all everyone's gonna play
are we doing doubles ours was for
fortnight so I don't know if we're end
up gonna do for tonight because the game
the game has he was having a server
problem
so which butts might cross might be for
sure we're really looking forward to
seeing Nick and Pete we have very high
hopes for him Nick we're relying on you
man yo what's up mr. one and only
hip-hop gamer hot 97 you see this doing
Nick I'm a murderer we gonna play smite
I'm a murder room you gotta say it like
that
let's go I never played smite before man
there's a little curveball fortnight's
down we're not playing the main game is
smite we need a crash course right now
when in doubt go to youtube flew us up
to New York to play a game we've never
played so thankfully they're pairing us
with a few professionals miters on our
team so hopefully they can kind of give
us a crash course we can be good wingman
and hopefully our team come out
victorious
[Music]
number three the rights and protections
of the Constitution applied to the
government not to private parties now
while certain provisions of the
Constitution will prohibit private
parties from acting in certain ways the
Constitution as a document applies to
the government not to private parties
remember this next time someone says
that say corporation X Y or Z is doing
things like prohibiting free speech the
Constitution as a document doesn't apply
to them cities and states cannot make
laws that are unconstitutional however
they can make laws that are more
restrictive than the Constitution take
the subway for example if New York City
decided that everybody on the subway
needs to take a camera with them they
could do so and it wouldn't be in
violation of the Constitution however if
for some crazy reason the federal
government decided everyone on the
subway must carry a camera with them
then obviously New York couldn't make a
law against that they could however make
a law that says on your camera you need
to have a microphone and a strap this is
how cities can make laws that are more
restrictive than the constitution
without necessarily being
unconstitutional and it's the other side
of the constitutional coin when it comes
to the ninth and tenth amendments that
we were talking about earlier number one
the rights listed in the Bill of Rights
are not created by the Bill of Rights
the common misconception is that the
most famous constitutional rights
freedom of speech freedom of religion
right to privacy even the right to keep
and bear arms are created because
they're listed in the constitutional
amendments this is simply not true these
rights are written down in the
Constitution as a reminder of our
unalienable rights that means that they
can't be given to or taken from the
possessor they are they are natural
rights that exists in every human being
from the moment of birds this follows an
Anglo cultural and philosophical
tradition that goes all the way back to
the Magna Carta the British Bill of
Rights in 1689 and is also listed very
clearly in elegant prose in
preamble of the Declaration of
Independence 13 years before the
Constitution we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights amongst these
are life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness at the end of the day it's our
responsibility not just as americans but
as citizens of all countries in the
world to read the foundational documents
of the countries in which you live and
work to understand what those mean for
you and your loved ones we can talk all
day about how there are shortcomings to
freedoms but knowing the great documents
that set the stage for Nations and the
freedoms within those nations is the
first step to ensuring that those
freedoms are protected if we do this we
can overcome anything if Nick wins this
then it's the first one was a fluke
personally I was like nah that wasn't
really that wasn't really meant to be if
you exist in a whole nother game a whole
nother City they don't give him the belt
I'll take the bill from that other guy
that I don't know did you see his belt
I'll take his belt I'll give it to Nick
and I'll buy you whatever dinner you
want buddy
back in there get you out of the game
man
I just gotta keep up momentum
[Applause]
I mean I'm trying to do something useful
for my dear
[Music]
I came to New York City to be a champion
dreaming of glory to see my name in
lights
I suppose that after every dream you
have to wake up I failed at holding my
championship title in a game that I've
never played before I let down my
friends myself and my country where will
I go next what will I do when I get
there for now only the windows only the
wind
to the heat after the gaming tournament
he stormed off and he said he was going
to Central Park Nick we gotta go right
now
we've been looking all over for you have
a flight back to LA I was supposed to be
a champion we came out to New York I was
supposed to make everyone proud of me
Nick dude hey dude I am proud of you
you're really in it yeah
come on we'll make fun videos I just how
to be a Christian what we're all proud
of you dude we're all proud of you come
on man come on throw that thing away
let's go come on let's go come on
[Music]